mais ce qui suggère édito optimiste très
optimiste il pourrait annoncer dès ce
soir les grandes lignes d'un accord des
engagements entre troupes israéliennes
et troupes syriennes cependant les
détails et l'application aurait encore
besoin de remise au point le négociateur
voulait rentrer à washington mais il a
été invité temps par le président syrien
monsieur hafez al assad que par madame
gold amer à rester quelques jours encore
au proche orient après avoir passé la
journée à damas aujourd'hui mais ce qui
suggère devait regagner jérusalem dans
la soirée
l' attaque israélienne était attendue
mais elle a été plus rapide et plus
violente encore qu'on ne le croyait
cette fois il n'y a pas eu ou pas encore
d'incursions dans le sud liban comme
après kiryat shmona mais un bombardement
un bombardement à la roquette qui trois
heures durant a frappé des objectifs
civils pour la plupart des camps
palestiniens des écoles ou des immeubles
dans des banlieues populaires
le bilan n'est pas encore définitif mais
il sera certainement très lourd on parle
déjà de 35 à 40 morts
des mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles
avaient été prises dans les camps
palestiniens depuis la sphère de maalot
si bien que les victimes de ce raid
israélien sont principalement des
libanais pourtant cette fois on
n'observe pas de tension comme ce fut le
cas souvent par le passé entre la
population libanaise et la résistance
palestinienne
ce matin tout le monde se pose la même
question est fini ou bien y aura-t-il
d'autres raids israéliens peut-être sous
d'autres formes pourtant les libanais et
les palestiniens ne cesse d'affirmer que
le commando de maalot ne venait pas du
liban qu'il s'agit de palestiniens
vivant en israël et c'est bien là la
question politique fondamentale y at il
une résistance intérieure qui se
développe en israël les palestiniens
affirment que oui et par le raid contre
le liban les israéliens ont durement
fait savoir qu'il refusait de l'admettre